this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Jenny and I just want to thank
Cornell for inviting me to present today
and thank all of you for being here to
uh to share and listen today about cover
and player systems so I'm going to talk
about the climate resilient farming
grant program
the goal of the program is to reduce the
impact of the agriculture on climate
change and to
and to increase the resiliency of New
York State Farms in the face of a
changing climate so we want to help
Farms reduce their environmental
footprint and increase their resiliency
and their adaptation to this uh changing
climate
so our program follows the the New York
State aim framework
our agricultural Environmental
Management program helps provide a
framework for assessing farms for
environmental challenges and finding
opportunities to to plan so best
management practices to to improve their
their farm management
all of our programs go through uh local
Soil and Water Conservation districts
this really helps us
um work with a wide variety of farms and
allows the farm to focus on the project
and implementing the best management
practices and allows us to work closer
with the district on the grant
Administration and the district also
provides technical assistance to Farms
through our aim framework and really
planning these projects out so they're
successful
uh so our climate resilient farming
grant program was launched in 2015. to
date we've awarded 12 million to over uh
200 or to 200 Farms across the state
uh we use the comet planner as a way to
estimate emission reductions and for the
practices that we've awarded we've
estimated 320 000 metric tons of CO2
equivalent per year in emission
reductions so it's equal to removing
almost 70 000 cars from the road for one
year
I'm under CRF right now we fund projects
under three tracks the first track is
manure storage cover and flare systems
which we're focusing on today but we
also fund Water Management systems and
healthy soils and why which is our our
soil Health practices like cover crafts
and reduced till
uh so round five we had awarded four
million for CRF and round six which we
just announced we have 8 million
available
funding for the CRF program comes from
the Environmental Protection fund and as
I mentioned we have three different
tracts of funding for this round we have
four million available for covering
flares 2 million for water management
and two million for healthy soils
so our Focus today
you know why are we focusing a CRF on uh
cover and flare uh systems uh well these
systems have the capacity to immediately
impact both the greenhouse gas emissions
from the farm and the Farm's resiliency
to Major precipitation events
so it helps reduce the amount of methane
Emissions on Farm as well as helps a
farm adapt to a changing climate
the goal of of our track one pro
projects is to reduce methane emissions
from manure management through the
collection and destruction of methane so
projects must demonstrate a reduction in
methane emissions
a project should estimate methane
destruction potential based on volume of
storage number and type of animals and
type of storage
uh the fair flare component is present
to combust methane when produced and for
flare efficiency we
recommend that efficiency can be
improved by Auto ignition powered by a
battery or solar we actually saw in
Dale's flare that he had a solar panel
next to it or a direct connection to
electrical service
um also a windshield has been found to
help improve efficiency of a flare
we're also encouraging promo potential
for remote data collection this is
useful in maintenance of a flare as well
as in tracking methane destruction
currently a covered manure storage
exhausting to a flare is exempt under
vec's air resources permit
so Dale mentioned also a lot about how
adaptation and resiliency plays into
cover and flare a cover helps prevent
millions of gallons of rain water from
entering the storage so therefore
keeping clean water clean mitigates your
water quality concern especially during
major precipitation events that we're
experiencing
um this also reduces emissions
associated with the spreading Dale also
touched on this how uh you know not
having the rain water mixed in means
less uh
less volume to uh to spread on your
fields
it also eliminates rainwater dilution of
this important nutrient source for the
farm
so we also have a agricultural non-point
Source uh water quality programs this
was developed in 1993 to focus on water
quality issues in the state
um approximately 210 million has been
awarded through our Agnon point source
program and 13 million is available for
projects in round 28.
so this is just a small sampling of some
of the practices that are eligible under
our ad non-point Source program manure
storages are eligible as well as cover
and flare systems currently the flare
component is only eligible as match as
that doesn't have a water quality impact
whereas the cover does have a water
quality impact so that's cost shareable
under this program
so just to recap we but have two
programs um climate resilient farming
round six uh both of these programs we
just announced the rfps for so 8 million
is available under CRF and those
applications are due March 28th
for agonon point source grant program uh
we're in round 28 of that program
there's 13 million available and those
applications are due May 2nd
as I mentioned earlier we work with soil
water conservation districts on all of
our grant programs they're the
applicants and they apply on behalf of
the farmer so anyone interested in our
program should contact their local Soil
and Water Conservation District and
start a relationship on on planning and
developing projects for their Farm
these are some resources
um I will share my presentation with the
with the host so this is something that
um you can follow up on after the the
webinar
that's all I have to present today and I
will be sticking around for any
questions so I'm happy to answer any
thank you Jennifer thank you Dale
um
uh I will just uh start in with the
questions
um Jeff Miller asks what percent is a
cost share for the covers on these two
programs
great question so for CRF we actually
have uh increased the cost share to 80
80 percent uh State
um 20 farmer
um as of right now our uh ad non-point
service program is
um 75 State
um uh but there is uh that is actually
can can increase somewhat but that's
something that is um
that this is where the water districts
are are well aware of so
um they know all the details of the the
rfps they can help with that too
okay thank you
um Dale this is a question for you how
old is your cover are there signs of
wear any warranty provided maintenance
needed so far on the cover or other
components including separation what
percent or fraction of an uncovered
Lagoon would normally be from
precipitation
okay let's just start with the first
part how old does it cover signs of
wears and warranty provided
it's uh 10 years old this this summer
um I'm not quite sure on the warranty
anymore uh they did a little bit of
repair work very minor so far nothing
really being 60 mil it's very thick uh
the only place we've had a little
trouble is where the exhaust pipe leaves
it we've had to reattach that
um once but other than that uh nowhere
whatsoever
uh storage capacity it increases the
storage capacity by one-third by having
a cover on and keeping all the
precipitation out so it really makes
your storage a lot longer period of time
by having a cover on it
one benefit I didn't mention also
because we had an employee that worked
for us in his when his teens no cows for
us when he came back in his 40s and
worked as a carpenter for us for a
number of years he couldn't he asked us
one day how come it doesn't smell here
anymore
and it's because the Lagoon was covered
all the time and all that gas wasn't
coming off and creating a smell around
the barn site it's a huge benefit in the
neighborhood
um so maybe that's how we can segue to
the next question from Jim why flare it
all why not use for some economic power
use
why did you not do an anaerobic digester
energy production system and go with the
cover and flare
two million dollar cost for a digester
how much two million dollar cost for a
digester uh there was cost sharing at
one time but I don't believe there is
right now
um
as my brother and I are getting it
I'm that retired my brother's a little
younger the Next Generation under me
didn't want to have to manage a digester
I have three Junior partners and they
didn't want to go that far yet they
wanted to take a step
and we wanted to get going on on all
this but we didn't want to have to go to
a two million investment and it's all
investment yeah everything you have to
plan ahead and this was a five-year
program time we did separation everybody
has to understand you have to have
manure separation before you do the
cover or you will build up solids and
then you got to figure out how to get
the cover off and clean it out we've had
10 years there is zero solid build up in
it yet
one other question there was on it it
should be good for a minimum 20 years
they told us and I think it'll be quite
a bit longer than that
okay and have you had just back to
Alex's question do you have any issues
with your separation have you had any
issues with your separation separation
is a management issue on a on a fairly
regular basis there is a stainless steel
screw is pushing everything through
stainless steel screen they wear out and
you do have you had to have maintenance
with us and you rebuild them once a year
but the benefit to us
was um
a very large Financial benefit to go to
separation
stop buying sawdust and went to bedding
we had far less reduction in costs and a
huge Improvement in milk production due
to the increase in cow comfort it is the
softest betting out there and the cows
love it and will you the biggest secret
to make high production on a cow is cow
comfort give them a soft comfortable
life and they make a lot of milk
so another question from Jeff Miller
following on this what is the cost of
the manure separation
we had about a four hundred thousand
dollar cost into the entire project from
the beginning of Separation to the end
of the cover in the lagoon the
separation was about 150 000 including
the buildings and everything and about a
quarter of a million on the cover
so we had about 400 000 total and have
you had any meetings from not purchasing
the bedding
well the savings was three thousand
dollars a month just on the vetting
issue the um 10 pounds of cow a day
increase in milk production on on
that that would have at one time it was
at least
um six thousand dollars a week change in
profit increase
um I don't know what it is offhand right
now I haven't recalculated it but it was
a it was a lot of it was a lot of money
over the long run and no they don't pay
for themselves in the short term but um
a total benefit I would recommend it to
everybody
um can you explain the cost of the flare
the Claire itself I can't
um remember the exact cost being 10
years old
um this one has a had a full computer
system and everything with it
um and it was hooked in Wi-Fi and the
whole works so it could be managed from
a remote location all solar powered
um I do that I do know they make less
expensive players
um but it tracks how many cubic feet go
through it at any time total times
everything it's a very we like the
system a great and I think the new one
will have the same thing on it or
similar updated
um fifteen thousand dollars or something
I'm not quite sure now
um
are you considering uh fertilizing with
the cylinder pivot system
we looked at um diluting the manure
because the two ponds are only 100 feet
apart the water storage Bond and the
satellite Lagoon we looked at com
combining them and running them through
the irrigation system on that 150-ish
Acres the only problem is they really
recommend a liner in the center pivot if
you're going to run manure through it
due to the um effect of slowly wearing
out the aluminum and we didn't do that
at that time and uh we have since gone
to all uh we're doing of of the 11
million gallons we produced per year of
manure seven million gallons is pumped
through Overland through soft hoses and
then and and then knife hooked right to
the back of a knife around the back of a
big tractor and and knifed right in the
other five million gallons is hauled to
farther away Fields more than two miles
away two to five miles away by truck to
trailer offloaded into a big tanker with
a knife or rig on and knifed in in the
field there
um so uh the system we have now is very
easy and we works well for us
okay quickly two more questions have you
ever had a problem with mass dice
mastitis and how large is your cover and
uh how large is your cover
the cover is a three and a half million
gallon Lagoon so it's roughly a hundred
and some feet by 300 and some feet long
uh wide width and length mastitis is an
issue if you don't learn to manage it
um even though we tested the solids and
there are zero bacteria in them when
they're coming out of The Hoop Building
because of the heat goes 163 it
basically kills everything but bacteria
rapidly regrow in the freestyle we hand
rake freestalls once a day we lime free
stalls once a day we groom freestyles
with a hydraulic power groomer once a
week we read that three times a week our
somatic cell count averages 120 000.
um
Curry for the year during a winter smxl
will run 70 to 90 000 and in the summer
and the hot weather it might hit 150
000. we have very little mastitis
um it's a full Management program you
have to have it in it isn't just put it
in and not worry about it you do it you
have to take it all into account
and my last question which is for both
of you and I know we're over time is how
long should a farmer plan ahead if they
want to apply for these programs that
Jennifer's uh speaking of like like what
kinds of relationships do they need to
build and and how much time do they need
to anticipate in order to be able to
apply for these funding programs
from a pharmacy point a year ahead of
time you gotta have you got to know your
cost sharing you got to have all this
worked out and a plan too it's not we
are always applying for grants for
different projects and we are always
looking in our case two to three years
out while we're working on one we're
looking at two to three years away what
we want to do next
Amy John has a different
no absolutely reach out to your District
now though and start that relationship
and and start you know talking to them
about what your Innovative your vision
is and you know what you're interested
in looking at and and planning out those
practices does take a lot of time so you
might not be applying for this round but
you might be you know putting some
planning into place that you'll apply
for future rounds
um Agnon point source has
ncrf have typically come out
um
annually
um but uh so so there are you know there
will be more our rfps in the future and
um I will just also mention
um that CRF does support nutrient
management practices like Dale had
mentioned like drag hose systems and
manure injection systems
um we fund that under our track three
projects for soil health so we support a
lot of these different practices the
uncover and flare
um just definitely start you know reach
out to your solar water district and
learn more about what uh what we do
support
and just because you don't get approved
on one round do not stop applying keep
applying see if you can tweak the
program your application to make it a
little bit more environmentally
um effective and just keep applying
thank you both so much this is a great
introduction to this whole topic I'm so
pleased
um
we're gonna now segue to the technical
component of this project
um and I was going to introduce all the
speakers at this time but I think I'll
just introduce our next speaker
um
uh Jessica Skinner of just in
engineering um has been working as an
agricultural engineer in New York state
for almost 25 years
for the last 17 years she has owned and
operated just engine engineering pllc
The Firm concentrates in the
agricultural Fields working to assist
farms in both Environmental Compliance
and facility planning a large portion of
her projects include in our storage
separation and transfer Design Systems
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu